[Musique]
le jardin de simmons et son univers son
bien-être et son refuge
cet auteur de bandes dessinées
originaire de normandie à tomber sous le
charme de la vallée de la loire installé
allongé depuis une dizaine d'années il
n'y a découvert les plaisirs du
jardinage fascinant c'est un univers
absolument infinie on n'a jamais fini de
découvrir très humblement en avance mais
intense et plein de petites
satisfactions au quotidien de petits
bonheurs sans cesse renouveler sans
cesse nouveau des plantes qu'on a laissé
monter en fleur et qui tout d'un coup
attire une foule d'insectes étonnant
qu'on n'avait jamais vu avant là bas à
la basse bouche on entend quand même
beaucoup parlé un peu tout le temps en
ce moment de la fonte de la biodiversité
et de des espèces qui disparaissent des
quantité d'animaux qui s'amenuisent au
fil du temps et moi je constatais quand
même un petit peu l'inversé l'échelle de
mon jardin et j'avais envie de témoigner
du fait que si on laisse la vie venir
elle vient si on lui laisse la place
elle l'apprend rendre compte témoigner
raconter ses 10 ans d'expérience et de
découverte pour cet auteur de bd c'est
tout naturellement vers ses crayons et
ses pinceaux qu'il s'est tourné
c'était vraiment pas un sujet facile
parce que sur le papier comme ça a
raconté l'histoire d'un jardin ça fait
pas forcément rêver on sent pas les
rebondissements dont il y avait un gros
en gros défi un gros enjeu de mise en
scène pour réussir à rendre le plus
palpitant possible une
une épopée jardinières
oh
ça parlait de jardin je voulais parce qu
ils trop froid sur lui j'ai beaucoup
fait de livres au pinceau à l'entrée aux
chinois la plume qu'un très lisse propre
là on parle de bois de feuilles de
grouillement végétale animale donc j'ai
utilisé un une mine une mine noir un
crayon noir sur un papier légèrement
rugueux pour avoir un très un peu
vibrant un peu organique
et puis j'ai aquarelles et directement
l'oasis n'est pas à proprement parler
une oeuvre militante mais l'auteur
entend tout de même délivré un message à
ses lecteurs on a tous un rôle à jouer
aussi petit soit-il le jardin n'a pas
besoin d'être grand
on peut faire des choses merveilleuses
et s'émerveiller c'est pour nous aussi
enfin c'est tellement plus enrichissant
d'avoir un jardin grouillant d'une vie
qui s'équilibre qui s'auto gère plutôt
que d'avoir juste la pelouse qu'on a
voulu et les deux plantes qu'on achetait
l'oasis vient de paraître aux éditions
dargaud un faible le encouragement pour
tous les amateurs de plantes d'animaux
d'oiseaux et d'insectes en tout genre
bref toute cette biodiversité retrouver
[Musique]